في هذه المقابله الخاصه بصاحب السمو
الملكي الامير سعود بن طلال بن بدر محافظ
الاحساء ملفات عديده سنناقشها في هذا
اللقاء مع الامير الشاب الذي تولى هذا
المنصب في شهر مايو الماضي من العام
الجاري 20 22 على راسها استقبال مشجعين
كاس العالم وغيرها من الملفات اهلا بكم
سمو الامير
الاحساء تستعد لاستقبال الاف المشجعين
القادمين والذاهبين الى مونديال قطر التي
لا تبعد كثيرا عن المحافظه استعدادات
الاحساء لاستقبال هذا الحدث العالمي لحتى
بدايه الاستعدادات همم اكثر من سنه كان في
لجنه مركزيه بالقياده وتم وضع جميع
الخدمات فيها من صحيه الامنيه السياحيه
والتنمويه ايضا شملتها همم الهدف منها
نوفر اكبر حجم من التغطيه لخدمات الزوار
في كاس العالم ان شاء الله في قطر نحن
الان في اشهر فنادق الاحساء والذي تم
اعاده ترميمه همم مؤخرا البعض يردد ان
الاحساله تملك المقومات السياحيه
والاقتصاديه التي تجعلها جاهزه لاستقبال
الاف
المشجعينك
الحسا في 20 21 بناء على الاحصائيات
استقبلت اكثر من 800,000 زائر
150,000 منهم كانوا من خارج المملكه
العربيه السعوديه البنيه التحتيه اللي
موجوده عندنا بنيه تحتيها قويه الفنادق
اللي موجوده مع الجهات الرقابيه المخصصه
من وزاره منظومه سياحه منظومه التجاره
قاموا باعاده تاهيل كثير من الفنادق
والبيوت الريفيه عندنا اكثر من 5,000 مسكن
موجود اليوم ونرحب في الجميع مؤخرا تم
افتتاح عدد من المشاريع السياحيه والبعض
الاخر سموكم
انشاء او قيد الدراسه همم حدثنا سموكم عن
ابرز هذه المشاريع عندنا ابرز المشاريع
السياحيه اعاده النظر في تجربه سائح في
جبل قاره اليوم جاسيين نعمل مع القطاع
الخاص على اعاده التجربه بطريقه مختلفه
ايضا عندنا الواحه اكبر واحد في العالم
همم جالسين نسوي لها تجربه تكون ثريه
وعندنا ايضا التجارب الاخرى اللي موجوده
في
المنظومه السياحيه عندنا اكثر من 65 موقع
سياحي اثري مسجل في اليونسكو جاسيين نقوم
بادوار مختلفه بان وزاره
الثقافه
وزاره سياحه لوضع افضل تجربه للزائرين في
همم الحسد ايضا في مشاريع اخرى سموك في
الفتره المقبله ايضا غير المشاهد كلمتها
ان شاء الله جميع المشاريع القادمه بتكون
تحت مظله هيئه تطوير الاحساء وهي هي جاءت
همم قبل سته شهور بامر ملكي اا برئاسه سمو
الامير احمد بن فهد بن ابي امير المنطقه
الشرقيه وتم وضع خطه استراتيجيه جالسين
نعمل عليها الان لضم جميع الركائز اللي
نحتاجه من سياحه وثقافه وايضا ترفيه
والبنيه التحتيه لوضع جميع المشاريع تحت
مظله واحده وتكون كلها مرتبطه مع الجهات
الاخرى طال عمرك السكان الاحساءلون كثير
على هيئه تطوير الاحزان
بعد وقت طويل يعني من الانتظار
هذه الهيئه هل تعود عليها كثيرا
لنقل المحافظه من مستوى الى مستوى اخر
فيما يتعلق
بتقنين المشاريع السياحيه متابعتها
الرقابه عليها التشريعات اللي موجوده في
المحافظه
طبعا القياده
مهتمه جدا بالاحسان
الهدف من انشاء الهيئه لوضع ركائز اساسيه
في بناء تنميه مستدامه هذا الهدف الرئيسي
منها المرحله
اللي موجود في المنطقه وايضا وش الركائز
اللي بتقوم عليها الاستراتيجيه
وايضا البنيه التحتيه اللي موجوده سابقا
شلون نقدر نوفر بنيه تحتيها افضل للخدمات
اللي موجوده كامله البنيه التحتيه بالنسبه
للفنادق في الاحساء سموكم كم هو عدد
الفنادق في
الاحساء واكيد طلعتم على مساله ارتفاع
الاسعار ومضاعفتها لاكثر من مره
هل تابعتم هذا الجانب هل لديكم تعليق عن
هذه الاسعار طبعا حدث عالم اللي بيحصل
ازدياد الاسعار مع الطلب اللي موجود لكن
شكلت لجان وتم الدراساتها مع الجهات
المختصه وايضا من الامارات المنطقه
الشرقيه في محافظه الحساء
الطلب اللي موجود عالي
والحدث عالمي لكن زياد مع الموسم القادم
راح يكون عالي جدا مثل ما روج له سابقا
بيكون الاسعار يعني متوسطه ولكن في خيارات
كثيره ايضا في الفنادق خمس نجوم في اربع
نجوم وايضا عندنا نزل للريفيه نزل الريفيه
بتغطي اكثر من 1500 نزل ريفيه موجوده في
الاحساء بتكون نازله في برنامج اير بي ام
بي ايضا هذا بيساعد على الخيرات اللي
موجوده اللي بجلس اكثر من يومين ثلاث ايام
يقدر يستفيد منها ويشوف تجربه جديده في
الاحسن همم سموكم همم ما هي الاثار
المتوقعه اقتصاديا على الاحساء وعلى ايضا
السعوديه همم خلال كاس العالم في قطر طبعا
ما في شك
الاقتصاد المحلي بيكون فيه انتعاش جميع
النشاطات همم وهذا الهدف من اليوم اللي
نقوم فيه من تحسين الخدمات اللي موجوده
همم اليوم همم الهدف همم لجاثين نركز فيه
توفير الخدمات كامله وايضا الاستثمار فيها
لضخها في المحتوى الموجود في الاحساء ست
اشهر قضيتها حتى الان في
المحافظه كيف شايف التفاعل اهالي الحساسه
العائلات الشباب الشابات تحمصهم اولا لكاس
العالم ثانيا تحمصهم لمدينهم للمحافظه
لتطويرها كيف لمست هذا الشيء الحمد لله
همم من وصول
الكرم والضيافه
والقوه شبابيه الموجوده في الحساء تغني عن
اشياء كثيره نحتاجها من خارج الاحسن اليوم
المشاريع اللي موجوده من مشاريع ناشئه
وايضا السوق اللي موجود سوق جذب للاستثمار
بين سياحي وترفيهي وايضا للاستثمار العام
في البنيه التحتيه فهل الحساء ومن ياتي من
خارج الحسن رحب فيه والرحب في مشاريعهم
وقال له اهلا وسهلا ختاما سمو الامير
رسالتكم الى الاف المشجعين والسياح الذين
سيزون الاحساء خلال مونديال قطر
اهلا وسهلا من داخل المملكه وايضا من دول
الخليج ومن العالم كله لحساه تمتاز بالقوه
البنيه التحتيه اللي موجوده والخدمات
جميعها والفنادق ونرحب فيهم واهلا وسهلا
فيك الوقت ختاما
سموكم على اختيار قناه العربيه
للحديث حول كاس العالم واستقبال الاف
المشجعين في الاحساء خلال الايام القليله
المقبله شكرا جزيلا